tropicana palms offers retirement living
at its finest we paid them a visit
to get a closer look at this amazing
55-plus community
this is tropicana palms
here at tropicana palms residents don't
move here to retire
they come here to live now i can tell
you all about this beautiful community
or we can go inside and talk to linda
the sales manager who not only works
here
but she lives here come on
linda j.c it is so good to see you
oh it is good to see you first things
first how has tropicana palms been
handling the pandemic
we have been doing great we have been
open during covid
but safety first masks and social
distance
we are offering self-guided tours for
people's comfort
as well as some guided tours but with
social distance okay i love the fact
that you put safety first
and i'm in love with this kitchen tell
me more about this kitchen
this is one of the gems of our
collection i love this home the
beautiful wood plank floor
the large farm sink
this island where you can enjoy
breakfast which is absolutely lovely
and then of course a large walk-in
pantry
everybody loves this this pantry it's
like an extra bedroom it is so big well
for somebody your size
all right so linda you guys make it so
easy for your future residents
to move in what are you guys doing right
now uh we we
have a finance partner that we work with
you
we've got wonderful programs right now
i've got a five thousand dollar down
i've got a special for veterans they're
all kind of things that we do
and it all handled here is smooth it's
kind of a very smooth process
you're looking out for your residence i
love it can you give us a tour of the
rest of this home
oh i would love to after you we've
carried the wood floors
throughout the remainder of the main
living part of the home
of course you have to have a large
laundry room
and then we have three bedrooms
which is great too because you have
family to come visit you you have extra
space and also maybe a man cave
or a man cave or an office you've got a
second full
bathroom that is very convenient to the
bedrooms
and of course the master suite it's a
big master bedroom back here
yes it is with crown molding but the gem
is the master bath you have his and her
sinks in there what else you have in
there
his and her sinks walk-in shower with a
bench
plenty of drawers and cabinets it is
gorgeous thank you so much linda for
showing us the place i love
spending time with you but i do have one
question
uh oh what did you bring the golf cart
yes
can i take it for a second short ride is
it out front yes it is
see you linda gotta go
[Music]
i love linda call calam properties
tropicana palms at
eight two three 702-456-5823 find them
online the address is on your screen and
remember
no payments until 2021 and only
five thousand dollars down on a new home
rocky